[Music]
in the next couple minutes i'll
demonstrate how easy it is to leverage
existing apogee apis to develop no code
applications
we're going to start in the apigee
environment where we have an open api
specification
an api proxy that represents that spec
and an api product which publishes the
api proxy
for client applications to consume today
an app created in app sheet will be our
client
in our hipsters products api proxy we
can see a pre-flow policy that checks
for an api key
this helps to secure the api as only
apps that have this secret key
can invoke the api next we can see the
api product that publishes the api
for client applications to use called
hipster silver
at the bottom of the api product
definition we can see that an app has
been registered
already for app sheet and this is where
we can get the api key for our app
now we're going to switch personas we've
been an apogee api producer up until now
in app sheet we will put on the hat of
paul parker
who's a line of business user the first
thing we'll do is create a data source
to point to our api
in apigee we'll click on the plus data
source
to add a new one we'll name the data
source apogee hipster's demo and select
the apogee type
we enter the api key from apigee and the
url to the open api spec
and now we can validate and then
authorize access to create the data
source
next we create an app we'll go to the my
apps area
app sheet noticed that we don't have any
apps yet so it's assuming we want to
create one
we do we'll use the start from your own
data option
and the data will come from our apogee
api
we'll call this app hipster's app now is
when we get to choose the apogee data
source we created
i'll select apogee hipsters demo let's
select
product app cheat just created the app
for us and we can see the preview of the
app
in the right pane already we just need
to make a few adjustments i know that
there's a picture of each product in
the data and that's not showing up we'll
change the picture type to
image the product id is kind of ugly
let's change the app to not show that
and then it will show the product name
first let's save our changes
now the images are showing up and the
product names look great
app sheet helped us create our first app
within a minute let's go to the tablet
view so that you can see a larger
version of the app
we can see that there's also a detailed
page created for each of the products
and we can navigate from product to
product on the detail screen
now let's go back to the summary list
once i've adjusted the app to be
just how i want it to be i'll be able to
deploy it to mobile devices
and as a web app this was a quick
overview of how to leverage your
existing apis to build no code
applications
are you ready to empower your business
users with appsheet and apogee